oh yeah I'm not expecting that kind of
commitment like whoa we're talking about
fake orgasms today how every lady has
done it except for some and those are
liars oh man
Nikki's emote calls all women lie so
just some the ones that aren't they're
lying
over the net I okay let's just go ahead
and say we are liars okay well who has
faked an orgasm but we always the last
five years audio people everyone's hands
were and then who's here for the audio
last five years I have for sure what I
hurried for the way I know and even I
had a discussion about it go I'll tell
you why this happened and I think this
is a pitfall that some ladies might fall
into is that when we first started
having sex he got me there
organically right but then I felt like
he took so much pride in it and he was
so elated that he could make me orgasm
through sex that I didn't want to take
that away from him so even if he
couldn't get me there like he would
almost pressure me to do it like where
it was like are you there yet
oh yeah and I was like hey it's so like
the pressure made me just fake it so
that he wouldn't be pressuring me
anymore
so I could go back to relaxing during
Eddie signed out I told him I was like
how many times did you do it because it
was affecting sex for me where I was
like I don't want to do this anymore I
don't live this lie because it was hard
it became increasingly harder to have a
real orgasm during sex he by the way
orally orgasms all the time like for me
I have no problem there but through sex
vaginally girls don't come every time
and there's a misconception that guys
think like oh if I know how to make her
[ __ ] once I can always do it doesn't
always happen that way
and put a lot of pressure on me and so I
had to tell him like it's affecting how
much I'm enjoying sex because instead of
me just relaxing and like being able to
let it happen I'm I'm trying to please
you by
showing you that you're giving me an
orgasm because it does feel good it just
isn't there yet and I feel like you're
waiting for it instead that's the number
one thing that I hate and I've noticed
that since I've been dating around any
guy that's waiting for me to come I can
tell yeah waiting or he's just like oh
like what do you want me to do and I'm
like I get I love lucky - and I love
that but just don't sit there waiting
around for it because or like you know
they're trying that's the bleep on us
and you know it's funny we talked so
often about things did and we say it a
lot on the show things that women do to
validate themselves and unhealthy ways
that we try to validate ourselves and i
genuinely believe and you know comment
or just correct me if i'm wrong because
i know that you will men often validate
themselves through sex and whether they
can make a woman finish or not i mean it
validates the size of your dick how good
you are in bed your physical
attractiveness and if she doesn't come
and sometimes you feel like am I good
enough so that's that's definitely how I
feel yeah like on like if if Casey's not
coming I'm like what did I do wrong like
what's happening so I get it white guys
would feel that way but they also need
to understand it's a lot more
complicated and sometimes you just got
to know your lady like this is it a must
that she has to finish and if she can't
if she has to finish and figure out
other ways instead of like just like
pummeling yeah favorite word I would
much rather not come during sex if it
doesn't happen organically and then
after he's done we know we finish oh
yeah whatever yeah it's like for me a
hundred percent like I am NOT a need to
finish kind of gal and if I do it's like
oh cool that was a cherry on top I
wasn't expecting it like I'm not I'm not
like trying to get there every single
time and that's why for me like in my
marriage I've never faked it cuz I just
tell him straight up like no it didn't
happen this time it's okay it's cool
let's move on and like did it take a
while for him to be like okay I get it
um well it's cuz for him to like he
actually for a long time he had like a
thing where you would take a long time
for him to finish so then we were both
are you okay I she was messing with her
she was touching
like oh I was just you know you're very
you know I'm so comfy no but yes so the
thing is that we were both like kind of
not always getting there so we would she
was waiting and then you were like I
know something is waiting is just like
it's actually been a thing with him well
now it's not so much a thing anymore but
ever since like with his previous
partners like he just would never finish
or like not never but it was just very
rare when he could get he doesn't like
sex is not satisfying for him probably
like something else is probably more
satisfying yeah probably
like there's a lot of guys like I've
dated a guy before and when I was in
college he was just more into like porn
and stuff so like for him sex wasn't it
wasn't interesting so you know he would
never finish so I've I've definitely
seen that be an option too but then yeah
like if the guys like waiting or cuz
yeah I hate that one guys waiting for
you to come I X she was really into
anime titties like really really
important no anime titties Oh what is it
just cartoon titties yeah cartoon
titties that are bet breasts do not
always bounce like that okay they're not
just doing a full-on circle that is what
Hannah my before I see what the kids or
watch it's like trying to water balloons
it's like I can swing trying to [ __ ] me
so hard that mine takes to a circle like
I mean that like in the realistic
expectation yes by pornography Wow
that is actually my tits aren't loose
they're not gonna bounce like yeah
they're like he wants to put me so hard
that my own breasts like slap me in the
face and I'm like listen up son it's not
gonna happen it's not gonna happen and
that's very that's stressful
like imagine laying there and you know
that you're not good enough but you're
still expectations of planet
it's like a carnival game like needless
to say we only dated for six months yeah
the first time I would never have I need
to figure out that hentai playground was
his favorite website so yeah
wait did you ever fake an orgasm with
him though did I you mean did I ever
work out do you think I'm trying to
think of all the times and he was
gyrating on top of me did I ever have a
real orgasm oh the answer to that
question is absolutely not did you fake
it yeah okay so for me personally the
main reason okay I kind of almost always
I didn't I think I've said this before
on the show I didn't ever had an orgasm
until I was like 23 Wow yeah any orgasm
like no or guys by you masturbating or
stimulating yourself yes I accidentally
hadn't orgasm the first wow yeah I was
listening to dubstep when the beat drops
really no it's not but like I was my
parents never was allowed enough that
like nobody could hear and so I was like
I'm going to try this vibrator that I
got in like in a goodie bag and I just
decided to give it a shot and it worked
it was crazy but I had never had an
orgasm prior to that and I was in really
[Laughter]
dub step gives me real orgasm take it
with men there was a time yeah there was
a time that I was on YouTube and that
song popped up in my recommend
embarrassing it reminds me of it I knew
exactly at what point it happened yeah
but I mean yes prior to that I always
either
I think I almost like always faked one
just because I I guess I felt like I
wanted the guide to enjoy the sack
which I which I think that it's kind of
a reason why a lot of people do and like
also like you kind of like okay are you
done yet I'm done it if it's going on
for too long a lot of times women will
fake which funny because it really shows
the miscommunication between men and
women because men are like oh I'm
supposed to last as long as possible but
you know women are like are you done yet
like 20 minutes max 15 20 minutes that's
like the max yeah and like if we're
gonna foreplay let's do a nice little
like 40 minutes of foreplay it doesn't
say that that's the only time or not the
only time but I remember with my ex I
would fake orgasming when he was going
down on me because he would not stop
until I came oh just let just stop like
there's enough like can you just like
jus enter now we had you don't need no I
just dragged him up I'm like no I do too
I I would do that to I'll just be like
come on like it's okay and he'd be like
no I watch it and I'm like okay because
you're into deep girl that exact thing I
don't know what it wasn't very keep
going cuz I would I would like to just
relax and let him go as long as possible
so I came but then it freaks me out
sometimes and now I know like I'm gonna
take too long
freaks you out why hmm you said it
freaks you out sometimes oh it used to
freak me out why yeah why oh because it
was I felt like I was taking too long oh
like you got in your head yeah we got in
my head and then I I think I just want
to hit them to feel bad like especially
that they've already been doing it for
15 minutes and it's not happening yeah I
didn't want to feel like they wasted
their time away now I'm finally giving
them the note like to like move a little
bit this way or that way so I now I just
completely communication immediately and
sometimes most of the time Steve gets it
immediately like where you don't even
have to talk about it he knows exactly
what to do but sometimes I just want
dick in me and Jesus yeah what that gets
a different type of stimulation
you know ones clitoral and one is
vaginal and sometimes I'm just like not
feeling the clitoral well I think what
it is what I've noticed for myself is
that like I cuz I've been single for a
while now it's like I can make myself
come basically and
it's kind of how I am is like almost the
same thing yeah head is so like if I'm
with a man I just want to actually have
the experience ring with a man which is
like he's on top of you and inside yes
so it's just like okay the the the like
oral sex part that's cool that's cool
whatever but I mean it's not the same
though just a mouth on your [ __ ] is not
the same yeah but the sex feels better
if he makes me come first orally yeah
this definitely feels better for me when
I think about there some guys are like
oh yeah I can last two hours be even an
hour but seriously with two hours I'm
thinking I do not want to be pounded
vaginal where my body that's for one
twelfth of a day what they're supposed
to do with it though that's what's the
two kinds of guy yeah you mean like two
hours of like start stop start stop
engine in trouble there's other
activities you know it's not just
constant pounding yeah but no it doesn't
tell you some people like literally like
yes you don't love this time did some
really if you're just straight pounding
a vagina for an hour it's gonna it's
gonna be dry it's like it's not gonna
there's nobody comes and they were like
we're done like maybe but then like oh
maybe not oh [ __ ] round two and then it
happens again and then like you know up
to baby four rounds that's my max also
I'm gonna just interject here and we can
cut this if we have to but I had to
explain cuz it just happened again
I have accidentally drank out of Nicky's
cup four times now oh my god actually
see in the clip where I reach down to
the lower one sip it get upset because I
really different level we started
rolling
I'm so mad because Nicky's kind of sick
and I don't want to get saved straight
and so I did a tequila mouthwash to try
to get the germs out and now I've just
come to terms with we are now bonded by
I'm so excited it's oat milk
transference to speak
oh god dude it's consistency god that
was very similar to me faking orgasm I
haven't done that probably since my very
early twenties so you know what question
I think that you you brought something
really interesting you said you you and
Steve I actually spoke about hey you
know I'm not always finishing sometimes
I kind of just do this it's a really
hard conversation they're couples to
have so I'm kind of I'm kind of curious
like how did you guys get to that point
how can other people get to that point
like how how did that conversation even
play out well I wanted I felt like I
feel like a good relationship is about
trust in honesty and stuff and I felt
like this was the one part of our
relationship that I wasn't being fully
honest about and it was because I was
protecting his pride in his ego but I
felt like I don't it wasn't healthy to
continue doing that I didn't like is
really not that feeling again it keeps
growing that's like just gross feeling
that you're yeah this guilt and so it
was a really tough conversation because
I was like he's gonna feel bad like cuz
Steve loves to please like he is really
just they just a great partner in like
how can I make you feel good how can I
get you there
even if it's like talking dirty to me or
putting me down because like I like that
[ __ ] but it's like he's a very like
giving partner and so for all of these
times when he thinks it's like when he
makes the bed and then I go over and
like remake it and like don't tell him
that I remade it because he didn't quite
do it right it's kind of that same
feeling of like oh I made you think you
were doing it right and the way that I
like you lose respect for him because
you see him as not really no because it
was this was different in the area of
like it was my fault like it was my
responsibility I didn't even mind not
not orgasming right like the orgasm
wasn't the goal for me but I knew that
it made him happy so it was almost like
my way of giving was by faking pleasure
right like I felt like that was my gift
like here
I'll make you feel like you did it but
it's that's not free I feel like that's
more emasculating than you know yeah
that's why it was a hard conversation
because I didn't want him to feel
emasculated but I kind of robbed him of
the opportunity to do it right and I
felt like that wasn't fair as a couple
like he wants to do it like a real
version of it so because he had had such
success in the beginning it was almost
like a downside because in my early 20s
I used to think that I couldn't get
there vaginally
so when guys would try to be like hey
just so you know like it doesn't happen
for all women like most women like
rarely come to vaginal sex and I go
through like these facts but then after
I did come for the first time during sex
and I knew it was possible it started
happening more regularly and so with
Steve it happened like right off the bat
and I it just was luck I guess and like
being in the right place at the right
time you're like cervix was in the right
place yeah and then he like kind of
expected that now or like I didn't want
him to think that like oh he did it so
good the first time I know this time
it's not good yeah and so I had to
explain all of this to him just like why
it why I started faking it and how I
never meant it to last that long like I
always thought like well it would I'd
stop faking it eventually but because he
would get so excited every time I did
come he didn't want to take that away
from no yeah and he'd get very like are
you coming in are you there yeah make
like beg for it before you come you know
like he got like very where I was like
oh no this is taking away like
relaxation part where you need the
relaxation in order to come like you
need that pressure to be taking off you
at least as soon you guys says anything
about me finishing I'm like oh now it's
not gonna happen yeah so I have a
completion of like hey don't pressure me
like whenever you do these things I know
it was his way of like being dominant
and like I am turned on by like him
making me do things but when it comes to
orgasming that's almost like the fake
part of porn like they're they're like
they're kind of a little stuck in porn
land yeah for that part of it exactly
yeah that's
it's fair and I feel like it's like a
communication thing because a lot of
times men and women we kind of just hold
on like that you know yeah supposed to
be mark yeah miss miss the mark like
it's just like you just barely met each
other oh come on yeah I I just feel like
that's something that people do a lot
and I you know what i similarly kind of
had a conversation I didn't have a
convert a verbal conversation with my
significant other like that I had more
of a physical conversation what is that
like I kind of was like early on I kinda
I think I think I want to say Effie I
definitely faked a couple but like it
was just so I didn't think much of it
and then as time went on like he was
like 75% of the time making me finish
and I wanted that to get to like either
a hundred percent of the time or to
either have a mutual consensus that hey
it may not happen this time
so what I started doing was like if I
wasn't in the right mindset like do you
guys ever know for a fact when you're
just not in the right mindset finish
yeah yeah you could have sex but like
you're just not gonna finish this time
and you already know it like maybe you
want to have a little of the physical
release but you aren't in the mindset of
like yeah I want to come yeah you know
yep so I so I would just start telling
him like like before we got into it like
I don't think I'm gonna finish but like
you know whatever let's do the thing you
know and then we went into it with that
expectation and then I just kind of
slowly just kept saying like oh yeah or
we might get into it and I realized I'm
not gonna finish and I just tell I'm
like I don't think I'm gonna finish and
you'd be like okay yeah and then we just
like kept it going and so now I haven't
faced one like I just don't at all
anymore and sometimes we have that
understanding but literally like the
majority of the time when we're having
just regular like intercourse like your
boys your boys good yeah like you don't
have to know and now when he makes me
come it's like it's like real so it's
better it's better just better all
around and just feels great like
everything feels great like I don't like
the coming is just the end of it like
like I don't need to finish during sex I
like to finish just you know at some
point like do you guys to get
different levels of orga organic they'll
like I don't know sometimes I won't even
know if I did because it would be like
such a like a level one but orgasm or
whatever and then so Casey ask me like
also did you like how was it home like I
think I came I don't know like I think I
came I did it uh-huh you don't feel as
good as after sex in the post coital
position underneath a Buffy comforter
did you say Buffy
oh she sure did we do right did my
favorite eucalyptus come she sure did if
you don't know what buffy is we have
been Buffy fan since day one
y'all know I've been in this I tried to
get a Buffy from my mom Nikki got the
Buffy and the Buffy duvet I got the buff
buff I take her to the dry cleaner I I
don't even put it in the washing machine
because I have to get dried I like dry
cleaners
um just whenever I feel like it's
starting to get dirty but it just it
really doesn't I don't sweat with my
buffy and if you're one of those people
that love just having a comforter on but
also turning the AC on get get the Buffy
yeah it's gonna be I mean we will give
you a discount code for it and then also
on top of that for the price you're
gonna have this thing forever
you're sleeping with it every single
night you know always spend money on
something that you are using every
single freaking night it's the most
comfortable bedding it's made from a
smooth eucalyptus fiber that feels even
softer than cotton it's breathable cool
to the touch and you can feel cozy
without overheating
everybody loves Buffy it has over 20,000
five-star reviews and y'all know people
don't always be reviewing you know that
means it's about 150,000 people that
love this blanket that haven't thought
of yeah you only brought that review so
Buffy offers a free trial you can try a
comforter in your own bed for free and
if you don't love it you can just return
it to Buffy at absolutely no cost so for
$20 off of your Buffy comforter all you
guys have to do tell me let's go to
Buffy Co I'm giving you time to type it
in right now
most actually don't even pause it just
keep it going Buffy see oh there you go
he got that
then add you Buffy to the cart and into
the code mood at checkout once again how
much y'all Dallas off your brand new
Buffy comforter visit Buffy CEO and into
the code mood oh yeah and you know while
you're sleeping in that bed maybe you
get hungry and you don't want to leave
your house so you call up Thor - that's
right because door - has something for
every lifestyle so I personally love
door - because I have a picky ass [ __ ]
I'm always like dude I'm kind of filling
some of this and kind of feeling some of
that but they have so many options so
many restaurant options because they
have over three hundred and ten thousand
restaurant partners in four thousand
cities so you will definitely find your
new favorite restaurant on door -
because I have my favorites I've listed
all of them every time I get hungry I'm
always looking through my list I'm like
okay this one this one today just one
right now Factory Chipotle yeah all of
them all your faves that's it and so
they do door to door delivery in all 50
US states Puerto Rico Canada and
Australia so with door - you'll never
have to worry about your next meal like
mwah coz with Casey he's always asking
me like so what do you feel like eating
I'm like I don't know let's look at door
door - and see what we got on the
favorites so anyway if you guys want to
order that's right it does save your
favorites so you don't even have to
think twice you just like okay let me go
order something that I know I like it's
just so much easier exactly and then I'm
such a basic [ __ ] - I end up ordering
the exact same things from the from the
restaurants that I love so aren't even
explore other things but you can how do
they get options right now our listeners
can get five dollars off their first
order of $15 or more when you download
the door - app and enter promo code big
mood that's five dollars off your first
order when you download the door - app
in the App Store and enter promo code
big mood don't forget that's promo code
big mood for five dollars off your first
order from door - big mood guys there's
gonna be some women that may not like
this and then
some that say oh these are some good
tips but we got to give it I mean we got
to give it out how to fake okay who
cannot fake an orgasm properly without
the in squeeze like think of it this way
wow this is what I'm thinking if there's
definitely some guys out there that are
watching this and are like I've never
been with a girl that faked it we're
about to shatter your reality yeah also
I'm wondering if there's a constructive
way of like if you realize hey maybe my
girl is like faking this maybe there's
room for a constructive conversation so
that you guys can get to a good place in
your relationship like you know when it
involves sex Jess yes what's the big
squeeze oh the big squeeze well if you
aren't already doing this what are you
doing what are you doing since you don't
believe that
okay so during sex right if you you have
to be able to control your vagina to
squeeze and also if you push it it
creates pressure as well so like you
need the inner squeeze and the outer
push so you need to be able to [ __ ]
suck that dick with the vagina anyways
okay listen I'm learning right now
because I don't do the push oh oh you've
gotta try birthing just built that
pelvic floor Wow ready girl I'm only
doing the little squeeze do I
interchange it stuffed in there yeah see
just just lay there for like a minute
you have to do this the whole time this
is just kind of like this is like an
intermediate thing you'll do did I do it
like involuntarily like okay yeah I can
be involuntary too but um during sex
like not not yeah yeah involuntary this
could happen as well but you if you want
to blow his mind a little bit make sure
you don't have to fart of course
obviously cuz there's a lot going on
here but if you're good you can push
push push with your pelvic floor like
you know I mean I close one eye we don't
forget him in the face like you're
having twins
just push while the Dickson side and
he's gonna be like oh it's gonna get
real time wet and let me let me just say
yes the push may be an aspect of faking
it but not everyone deserves the push no
not everyone deserved a push is for the
man you really love ya know the push to
put the Kegel where's Louise yeah so
that's just during sex so but then guys
I feel like that's for the end you guys
that have had no no no not necessarily
guys that have had sex with women and
they have had orgasms they will probably
have noticed throughout their lifetime
that a girl kind of like I mean guys
when they come there they have a like a
movement girls kind of like an
involuntary twitch or like a kind of
like a rapid squeeze thing that happens
but you can also fake that so don't
think that you made her [ __ ] just because
there's a rapid quick because you could
fake that too yeah you guys you know
that thing where y'all were dudes where
y'all are laying on your stomach and
your dick shows up and you can move
something yeah we didn't do that with
our vagina so yeah I mean like back I
only do the clutch like you have to
deserve it you know I'm like really you
know I think that that's like Darrell if
you can fake you like someone who has
made you come like because okay from
your example can know like for me I
don't think I could because my entire
body shakes
oh I faked the shake I can't fake a [ __ ]
you gotta fake the shake again I know a
girl that she when she comes her whole
body breaks out into a red rash for
curse at a past life
hey no because as soon as he sees that
he's like babe what is this she's like I
don't know you you like to masturbate in
traffic and [ __ ] then she won't like to
already was like Nikki after sex maybe
he goes in the bathroom starts lap dude
that way that would call it out I'm
trying to think of like what else I do
um you know what I oh god you know what
one of mine is one of my V Hales yes
we'll wait that I'm faking or one of my
add-ons Oh to the show I contact mmm
happens when you are having the real
wood or actually with both dude I can't
make eye contact my eyes are shut and
they rolled back that's good that's good
fakie thing do that if you know I'm
saying I did you obviously can turn that
on and off Oh Casey watches no but I'm
telling you like like I am like shaking
like shivering shaking when oh and also
I did this thing - it's [ __ ] exorcism
only if it's like a real head spin
you're vomiting I don't know okay like
if it's a really really strong orgasm my
entire body goes like oh absolutely your
oral sex for sure like the whole I think
like just like
do contortion moves like you like you
don't want that whole thing where
they're like a female orgasm lasts like
29 seconds or something like it's crazy
oh no it does they count the build-up
which can take longer the older I get
the longer my orgasms are like it's just
like maybe drops out on the floor starts
doing the stage I think I get the twitch
for a while yeah but my body doesn't do
it's like my whole body like it's just
like you know you have an eyelid twitch
my vagina will do that for oh that does
happen but no like my body has like
waves like for wild ain't nothing for me
to like it will happen where I can't
help it but my my thighs have to like
closed shut if he's down there I'm like
move yeah it rejected like like yeah you
know only I don't you know what I just
realized in a what I absolutely can't
fake what always happens is like in an
actual real orgasm I feel this immense
sense of like relief like there's like a
just full-on like oh and like I never do
that if I faked it I don't know I just
never you think about it you forget by
after release yeah I forget it like that
the house were faking it take those who
think that you have to relieve too but
yeah it's like I just feel like my whole
body like like like tightens up and then
like it's just like it drew yeah and I'm
kind of like happy
yeah but dopamine actually enters your
head system but it's funny because think
if I'm faking it I'm just nice what else
can you guys think of anything I'll say
like you don't fake that happens during
a real one how to tell do you guys ever
feel when you're like actually coming
like there's a coming out oh I never
feel no well the double shot
geez squirt I get dick drunk you guys
never get dick drunk
that's what c-can I call it so after I
orgasm at least two times take way it's
not more like multiple times I don't
care what he does to my body like he
could do he could flip me over he could
just like just I'm just dick drunk like
he's like you like it was like yeah it's
just I'm so like like relieved Oh
ragdoll yes I think so yeah I think so
I don't whatever you want daddy orgasm
crazy where I'm like I hit one hit two
let's go for three Oh like drill
sergeant I got not so relaxed that I was
like take me um yo yeah I actually like
you physically can't open your eyes
anymore you're just like whatever I
don't I could die right now you know I
just thought about another contrast
between faking it and serious okay
when a lot of times like if I'm fake if
I fake it it's like I'm kind of done
having so I'm just yeah okay thanks
we're done here but but you know of
course he'll still finish well you know
do some stuff but if I am absolutely not
faking it sometimes I get so dick drunk
that I'll let them keep going for around
two and three because I'm like oh maybe
I can keep going yeah yeah like but
sometimes I'll just be like yes Steve
I've never faked it to stop having sex I
kind of just faked it to take the
pressure off him yeah and off of myself
yeah and off of myself so I could
actually like relax in it more but I
kept I liked the sex part of it like I
wanted that to keep going I just didn't
want to feel like he was like waiting
for me I think um yeah it's been so long
since I've faked it because I literally
don't care anymore I'm like if you
didn't do it I'm not gonna lie to you I
don't know yeah I'm not gonna throw a
dog a bone I think when I was younger I
just felt like all right because I I
wasn't fully
since exit so I just thought I was
supposed to do that same is broken
I just thought no I'm just supposed to
do that like that's the part of his poor
yeah yeah yeah it's like that
yeah but for some reason I think is
because of movies like her movies yeah
you're like oh there's this highlight
that you're supposed to hit and you're
just like oh yeah yeah yeah I definitely
started having loud sex because of
movies like I made those noises because
of movies but then it became so
associated to actual pleasure that I
just organically have loud so you know I
read somewhere that when you're making
the sounds it actually turns you on more
yeah I probably hi yeah oh my god you
know what we should try and then report
back what if we tried going back to her
our significant others and tried having
like quiet sex I've been doing that
recently yeah I row if I'm having loud
if I like naturally loud he puts his
hand over my mouth and is like you're
not allowed to make a [ __ ] world oh
well that's - that turns me on so
there's like there's a thing going on
there's a game though yeah it's like but
irony of it is more of like it I feel
like it almost would become more
passionate if you're just focused on
each other and not really like the
sounds and everything like you have to
look for other tells that they're having
a good time rather than just the sounds
that's mainly mean Casey sex life that
like we we do like we still make sounds
but they're like we're restricting
ourselves also you can hit that's the
reason why yeah I don't know when I ever
have had sex with a guy and he's just
dead quiet I'm like are you alive what's
going on behind me I'm like are you
alive I feel like
just from the sounds but it sounds like
Nicky and I are probably out here having
this like porn star status sex we're
like I definitely my neighbors think
grooming is camera equipment all the
time we're always at home the most fun
sex session that cuz we've had some
great ones but like for me personally
the most fun one was this one time we
were in Vegas and that was the time
where I was like you know what let's
just try loud sex and we were just
[ __ ] loud and I'm like that was so
fun like so releasing yeah that's like
we could never do that cuz like you said
I get home so yeah dude my man that
would be hollering [ __ ] we'd be looking
at each other like cut two of you of
yours like
[Laughter]
I feel like we've we've touched on a
couple a lot of different things but I'm
really kind of interested in why women
fake where I was like we've kind of
touched on it but I just like want to
really rein it in I think there's a few
different reasons why like we want to
take like I feel like when someone
thinks my girlfriend has been faking
orgasms it's just like this is a problem
but it's like I want to dig a little
deeper and be like what exactly is going
on yeah like what can you what what
exactly are you doing in the
relationship that might make her feel
like she has to fake an orgasm
maybe it's herself like her own
insecurities were I know definitely
that's the reason why I would fake them
fake the orgasms cuz I would feel like
like I am broken I'm supposed to be
orgasming I'm not maybe if I faked it
maybe it'll count like it would actually
come by faking it til you make it yeah
exactly so those are kind of some of the
thoughts that I would have and then also
like I wanted him to feel good so like
I'm trying to like what you were saying
like trying to be like the the giver
like helping give him what he wants and
I don't know there's just like
exploitation
and then also the more for me at least
like the more I thought about needing to
come or wanting to come or trying to
come then the less it would happen yes
so then that would just make me feel
defeated so I'm like [ __ ] it let me just
[ __ ] let me fake it then yeah if I
could give guys any like word of advice
it would probably be to just stop saying
like oh yeah you want you're gonna come
right come on this dick or something and
I'm like oh my god me there's a little
there's a lot of reasons but also think
it whirls tend to do that to the guys
like I want you to yeah yeah and do they
think you know I really i'd like to
assist that about like I feel like I'm
broken I think that early on and I've
said this before on the show I didn't
really like see sex as an active passion
I almost felt like this is a thing I
have to do in a relationship and I
didn't want a guy to think that
something was wrong with me because I
couldn't finish
you know sometimes that happens to us
like in our early twenties like we just
don't want to be the girl that couldn't
come yeah we just like faked it and you
know it has nothing to do with you know
the it has something to do with the guy
not doing his part but it is something
important to address because it kind of
stops the couple from communicating and
figuring out how to actually have good
sex yeah because if he thinks he's
already got it got it in the bag because
we've been faking it then he won't me he
won't get there yeah he doesn't get to
work on his skills and it is important
for you to have that conversation
because you don't want to start to build
some resentment towards your significant
other because maybe you're thinking
about some guy used to date two or three
years ago that was giving it to you raw
raw making it explode yeah you know
thinking about you know past sexual
experience or fantasizing about certain
things when you know there's a guy in
front of you that loves you and wants to
take care of you I think it's important
for all of us to remember
I just want to make us finish they want
us to have a nice time during sex but we
have to communicate to make sure that
they meet our needs now also vice versa
yeah
vacation is really key yeah I think that
like you know what it is a it's not just
communication it's also communicating
with like being open and understanding
and accepting because there is you can
communicate all you want but if the
other person is not receiving it and not
wanting to understand and not I like I'm
taking it too personal yeah and then
you're never gonna get anywhere so
that's the other half to communication
is trying to be open is that a little
bit when we switch the subject like I
think a couple of times in my 20s are
like guys were not able to finish
themselves and I think for a girl you're
like wait what like you can't come all
you got to do is just [ __ ] jacket or
stick it in something you're gonna come
so if you're not coming yes what's
happening and now I'm taking this ship
personally yeah where it could be like
oh maybe he's still heartbroken over
something he shouldn't be having sex
right now or maybe he drank too much and
it's just not gonna happen or maybe he
jacked off too many times that week and
it's just not like so as women we can
definitely set that up for them too I
feel like there's probably some guys
that have definitely faked an orgasm -
yeah like especially if you're wearing
condoms you'll just they'll fake it and
they'll pull it off and then grab the
card and run to the bathroom like they
just couldn't finish how do guys fake
orgasms that's one way I don't think
they think that far they just go oh yeah
and then they just get out sorry I hit
the wall I mean definitely for girls if
a guy if a guy doesn't finish we're like
what's going on yeah we're totally
failed as like a Pete I've been there
hard the beginning of our relationship
it was it was really difficult and then
it got to a point where I'm like um you
know like is everything like am I am i
enough for you satisfying
yeah like are you good are we having a
good time he'd be like no yeah sorry
you just like I've always kind of had
this thing and then I'm like yeah okay
so it's not just me I dated a guy it was
actually the cop that we talked about
before he would never finish and and
then I feel like I kind of figured out
over time it was like he just really
liked porn but I think every guy has
their thing I feel like this guy thought
that he was this like very prowling
masculine guy or whatever but he was so
addicted to porn or he liked his
interaction with women was was very
closed off so he was unreal yeah he
could never finish in like that's a guy
it reminds me of the tumblr guy that he
just had to like do you know there was
what you know after he uncuffed me I
remember walking back into his room and
it had very high ceilings with so it was
like high vaulted ceiling and it was
some kind of like acrobatic poll going
across the top what's next but because
you know he was he was a tumblr sex guy
to tumblr had some crazy [ __ ] that's
like some xhamster some ex video stuff I
didn't even know about that until they
banned for and off tumblr and I was like
oh [ __ ] tumblr people were doing that
was for emo kids that posted poetry and
[ __ ] no dude people were I mean it was
mostly there was a lot of like porn porn
blogs and yeah this is the porn blog
blog a bug a porn vlog yeah they happen
this is called porn I'm thinking about
that like hey guys we're going to
grocery store and later we're gonna
[ __ ] make a lot of money doing that
like regular vlogs on YouTube yeah watch
part 2 at pornhub calm sorry-ass promo I
just gave somebody out there an idea get
your money girls tag me I could name
like three people right now that would
be into that
well after you have a real orgasm and
you get that relief mm-hmm you want a
good night's sleep but sometimes your
body's ready but your mind is still
awake and active exactly that's where
calm comes in which is my freakin
favorite app right now every single
night I I open up calm and I listen
to either sleep stories or to LeBron
James lately yes so LeBron James has
this like train your mind meditation and
there was this one thing that he said in
that meditation because it's like
multiple one so you can go like every
night and like listen to the next one
and there was just there was something
that he said in it that I'm like I'm
getting this tattooed on me but it made
me cry it was really insightful and it
was like I loved it I absolutely
recommend this app I actually send it to
my cousin too because she's been having
trouble sleeping and I'm like you need
to get this app and make sure to use our
code and which I'll tell you in a second
but anyway back to call so they're
saying that yeah for me it's like not
even about trouble sleeping coz and this
is why I like come because there's so
many uses for it but I have no problem
sleeping but I have crazy anxiety when I
am awake and calm really helps to like
reduce that anxiety reduce stress keep
me just present and focused and in the
moment yeah like so it's a mental
Fitness app that's designed to help you
relieve anxiety and improve your sleep
and it ease it helps ease ease your
stress and it helps you get the best
sleep of your life so calm has an entire
library of programs designed for healthy
sleep like soundscapes guided
meditations and like I mentioned before
they have sleep stories so for listeners
of this show calm is offering a special
limited time promotion of 40% off a calm
premium subscription at com.com slash
mood that's 40% off unlimited access to
calms entire library and new content is
added every week so get started today at
com.com slash mood
that's com.com slash mood also thank you
to our sponsor honey book if you're a
small business owner you got into your
line of work because it was your passion
you don't want to do all the extra Boosh
it that comes with running a business
now you don't know you you just wanted
you don't wanna do tedious admin work
you want to do the fun stuff so honey
book is an online business management
tool that organizes your client
communications bookings contracts
invoices all in one place it's perfect
for freelancers entrepreneurs or small
business owners that want to consolidate
the server
they might already use like QuickBooks
Google suite Excel and MailChimp
that's a great consolidation all of in
all of those apps do completely
different things and should shows you
how versatile honey book is to get it
all in one that's great one can automate
your busy work they have easy to use
templates for emails proposals brochures
and invoices they also have East
signatures built in automation to save
you time you get paid faster simplify
your to-do list and stay in control with
honey book and right now honey book is
offering our listeners 50% off that's a
huge discount when you visit honey
book.com slash big mood payment is
flexible and promotion applies whether
you pay monthly or annually whoa go -
honey book calm slash big mood for 50%
off your first year the whole year so I
could just get it annually and get 50%
off and get a little cheaper when I do
it annually - honeycomb slash big mood
check it out you know I was thinking
about I've only faked it with guys that
I care about when I was dating I the
none of them made me come but I liked
the sex but they didn't make me come and
I didn't fake it like I just we had sex
and it was over I knows whatever um but
with the guys that I care about is the
one those are the ones where I was like
oh I care about how they feel because I
want to express that I enjoy this how
can i express to them that I enjoy this
like oh no yeah
I'm trying to go back in my rolodex here
dating currently I don't yeah I think
it's probably a mixture of two maybe
some I like wanted to hurry up and get
rid of so I pulled that so it's like the
opposite where do you wait for them to
finish your no yeah yeah I mean I never
if I'm if I've already gotten to the
point of having sex I'm not gonna just
cut him off unless he's doing something
super [ __ ] weird which hasn't really
happened only one time well with that
one time okay
okay okay so this guy so we were playing
around like kind of before we really got
into the sex I don't think even put it
in yet so it was just like foreplay
right so I'm at some point I don't even
know how I got to this position but I
was on all fours like you don't know how
you got on all fours
he was sitting behind me so imagine me
like you know on all fours and he's just
sitting behind me and then he's like got
his hand and he's like Oh
jackhammer ah you're like a staple good
wait a minute this is [ __ ] not good
you know I was like what are you doing
just if I can put it in you know but he
kept wanting to do that I feel like he
saw it in a porn and you thought that
like oh I'm gonna make her come join
action it was like because yeah I don't
know it was just really bad had you
stopped I was like don't do that and he
goes no you like this that was the only
time where I was like we you need to
stop and then I just left so you guys
didn't even have said no I was like nah
bro you ruined it like because like I
get that he was trying something new but
it was the whole like he wasn't getting
the hint that I was like no I don't want
he's like no you do I've seen all the
girls in poor and they like this
actually said that I did sense the vibe
one time when a guy was going down on me
it was a boyfriend so we were dating but
he was going down on me and he did one
of these like and I I know they do that
important but saliva grosses me the [ __ ]
out like I don't know like it's I know
that you're using saliva down there but
I don't like drool I don't like my lips
I know a lot of like it but I don't like
oh yeah excessive wetness different
strokes also just didn't yeah they like
hardcore loogie I guess I was like why
would you do that I
I mean he got so engrossed out yeah
there's a lot of spit insects but sure
it was like yeah like bacteria like I
don't like the phony bubbling bubble
spit playfully
visualize it no you're definitely right
though I'm net wall I was gonna say I
don't know if this is for me personally
I I will say if I don't like you I'm not
gonna fake it because why but I'm but
also like I can't it's kind of hard for
me to say to you because I've never
slept with somebody I didn't like did I
thought that question came out of me
what out of everyone here because I have
had sex with people I don't like
[Laughter]
feelings for them yet yeah yeah yeah I
don't like I'm just not gonna fake it
and be like nice yes yes say how do you
end that wait how do you in sex if
you're not gonna fake it I guess um like
it was just when the guy came yeah I
honestly I would just tell him like I
just I want you to come so badly now so
just come are you just like agamotto
the guys that were just random hookups
for me um like the way they weren't too
concerned with me coming yeah that's
true I mean I don't think they carry
their yeah yeah yeah I definitely have
done that egged on thing like oh yeah
yeah yes make it about them aboard sir
yeah hotline sex because like you don't
have to be in it yours like oh yeah oh
my god I really like this oh man you got
it daddy
you got it you got a home I feel like so
many people are doing only fans right
now where are the modern-day sex
hotlines like I'm giving it I'm giving
out so many businesses see those
commercials anymore you don't do but I
feel like phone sex is so much more
interactive than then like then like I
think they do still do it cuz once a
phone sex operator was interviewed for
Shambala
bro I'm about to make a website on
ladies come to my website you can text
anonymously you paid $100 Secession I'm
booting this [ __ ] up right now I just
thought yeah I want to own a phone sex
hotline anonymously let me collect the
check everyone's Instagram subscription
promo I gotta get that I get this going
before this episode if both starts
randomly promoting a sponsored sex
hotline ooh is it is it anonymous can I
be like lady just yeah yeah yeah perfect
yulik because especially because we're
in the only fans era where like your
face isn't everything like why not be I
feel like I would knows you like you
like five characters like this is a pose
character hey hey big boy pucker up hey
son nice trousers you got they look even
better on the floor like yes I got bows
this time I don't try it just once but
like what kind of guys call that that's
what I want ah dude very really really
old married guys
I feel like previous era okay if you're
looking at photos of girls you have to
kind of create a story in your head but
if you're on the phone here's the story
like it's right there and I feel like
it's more like anonymous than it is with
photos yeah I probably would try like
camming you don't have to take care of
yourself you could go like I just got
out of the there was that reputation
that they were all just like big huge
big
girls with like chips in their hair and
so I saw Ladakh were like I think it was
to catch a predator or like the girl
that was doing the voice of a
fourteen-year-old she was like not a sex
hot line looking person Wow wait for
teen sex hotline no well so if To Catch
a Predator was the yeah I saw the dog
was she's supposed to like be flirty and
she like has this like high voice and
stuff and they were catching the
predator but she was like a 39 year old
you know freeze everything I lost my
voice and it started coming back I'm
always like I could totally be a hotline
operator dial
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
your face or something like that is just
really important to me and but now it's
a little more acceptable but I'm like I
wonder if there's still a way for women
to be sexually free but without kind of
risking your career how can your head
not impose is the pimp of the anonymous
sex worker yeah so guys I don't know
what did I think I learned something I
learned about the pole today learn about
the push today different reasons people
might fake an orgasm it's not all bad
it's not all like here's your ego I'm
taking an axe and I'm crushing it's not
all that I really hope that you guys
kind of drew something from this episode
male or female if you did make sure you
share with your friends if you whenever
you guys tweet or respond to a tweet
that's like what's your favorite podcast
and you mention us we always yes we will
favorite it will love it but yeah share
with your boys share with the girls
we'll see you next week and check out
this new series should be out soon I
think it's out this new series is out we
have two new ones waters days come back
on Thursday yeah I'm all and you know
what we'll see you next week for this
job peace bye guys don't forget to rate
us